[Music]
How are you greetings by Cristian Cásseres with
his brief information on Kirchner in
Spanish? Parents and students vocalize
their opinions at the first
face-to-face meeting of the
Clark County School District in almost a year and
asked administrators to open the
school campuses of  full-time
some parents expressed the challenges
their family members have faced with
school closures other parents cited
medical experts who say that the
return of students to campus
basically presents no
greater risk to communities
students were also present
speaking about the  difficulties they have
faced with
distance learning at the moment there are no dates
for the full-time return to
high
school students and on Monday thousands of
students will start classes under the
hybrid education plan students will
start classes on Monday they will be able to
attend classes presence  two days
a week and home three days the return
to school will apply to students
crossing grades pre-kindergarten to
third grade and students and some other grades will
meet the phase plan by the end
of March
during the month of April
and  there is important information that parents
should know before the first day of
school among the new guidelines that have
been implemented are the
start and end times of classes the first
of the school district
certain entry and exit points have been designated on their
campuses students who travel by
School buses will be the last to
leave the campuses to ensure that
the buses arrive at the campuses
after the dismissal bell by
this measure parents are reminded
that they cannot go to the campuses
to wait for the dismissal of classes
this measure  It has been implemented to
avoid crowding and
maintain security measures in the face of
the pandemic and finally we give it a look.
The temperatures here in
our region are expected today to be a
sunny day with light winds but it will
increase for tomorrow the
temperatures will be nice
reaching almost 60 degrees and a little
cool for the weekend but there will be
an increase in temperatures for  the
next few weeks reaching almost 70
degrees I'm Cristian Cásseres with his
brief Disney news in Spanish
Happy Friday
[Music]